we're told that particles a and b are
moving along a plane
their velocities are represented by the
vectors vector a and vector b
respectively
which option best describes the meaning
of the following statement choose one
answer so pause this video and try to
work through this on your own before we
work through this together
all right now let's work through this
together so this is saying that the
magnitude of vector a
is equal to the magnitude of vector b so
we know that a vector is specified by
both a magnitude and a direction and
this is just saying that the magnitudes
are the same so for example vector a
could look
like this
and vector b could look like this it
could do something
like that
where it has the same magnitude and the
same direction or vector b might be in a
completely different direction the
magnitudes being equivalent just tells
us that the length of these arrows are
the same but we could have different
directions here
so what this tells me is that we have
the same speed which is the magnitude of
velocity but not necessarily the same
direction
now let's look at the choices here the
first choice is the two particles move
at the same speed and in the same
direction
so we've already said that that's not
necessarily the case in order for choice
a to be correct they would essentially
have to be equivalent vectors choice a
would be the case if we said that vector
a is equal to vector b then they would
have to have the same magnitude and the
same direction the same magnitude and
the same direction but that's not what
they told us they just told us that the
magnitudes are the same not necessarily
the directions so i'll rule that one out
the two particles move at the same speed
but not necessarily in the same
direction
yes that's what we just talked about
they have the same speed which is the
magnitude of velocity but they didn't
tell us anything about the direction
just the magnitudes so i like this
choice but let's look at choice c
the two particles move in the same
direction but not necessarily at the
same speed
well we know they move at the same speed
that's what this is telling us the
magnitudes are the same we just don't
know anything about the direction so i
would rule this one out as well in order
for choice c to be the case you would
see something like this maybe that is
vector a right here and then vector b
would move in the same direction
but it would have a different magnitude
and here you would visualize the
magnitude as the length of the arrow but
that's not what they told us they told
us this right over there